look who I found what's up my boys guess
what we're eating today you'll never
know
Korean barbecue my name is Steven that's
Andrew that's Adam and today we are on
our way to e3
Korean barbecue experiences at three
drastically different price points to
find out which one is the most worth it
at its price we have a special guest a
Korean guy I wanted to bring somebody
who really knew how to eat Korean
barbecue Evan gong you know all the
names of the meats in Korean you know
how to order you know the etiquette how
often do you eat Korean barbecue Evan so
every two weeks I don't know that I do
anything every other week you on the
east trip with me oh god the first place
we're going to this an all-you-can-eat
it's not that cheap actually it's $24
per person but that's the best value
you'll get anywhere what's it called
that right oh wow
he says it better than you man I mean
I'm not Korean so we're both equally not
Koreans my name is Jaden I'm a waiter
and today I'm gonna be serving you guys
all-you-can-eat Korean barbecue right
now is lunch price so you guys got are
gonna be charges $23.99 we have a lot of
different types of of you thirty two
options how would I recommend number
five of six which is Black Angus hanging
tender and outside stripper
there's vada Korean barbecues in
Koreatown but it's only us who has it
when we said so special once we cut the
meat it's really hard to manage to me
the color changes taste changes only few
mouth comes out once you cut it be
getting me at every morning we cut it
and the servant into thing next day we
get the fresh music if I see there's
grills everywhere who cooks the meat you
guys normally flip it but we come right
help you guys a lot so money after you
can have 32 different meats I think yeah
let's do it
what is happening what is that this is
the side dish what is that
Ondra is that what is that I don't eat
the side dishes for me I just eat it cuz
I'm hungry I can't wait until the meats
being cooked
I'm gonna do it that way but you usually
eat with me too I just pour the sahjhan
beer so being youngest I am I have to
pour you guys drinks which wins by two
hands I know we respect ya one-handed
pour it's kind of like I have to receive
it two hands now seriously yo legit
Stephen usually lies to be honest reason
why we're in this purse is because they
cook really fast so you have to torture
yourself watching me pinko being the
youngest of the bunch I have to cook I
love this youngest of the baby that's
why I brought him I just sit back and
eat the best way to cook meat is you
only put there once if you put a bit
more than twice it gets too dry you go
ahead and eat now these are ready even
if it's a little thing beef just fine
you know when your mom is cooking dinner
you sneak in the kitchen you steal a
bite of whatever they're eating it's
like that guilt eat in the middle of
cooking deliciousness I'll show you guys
how to make the wraps you open this up
you can honestly put whatever you want
but I'd like to put garlic in they just
eat it you're saying that we could get
as many as we want
you do realize Andrew will pull you out
of business yeah see if your press
button the number shows up on the screen
so he knows we're just able to go to oh
that looks so good
oh no I'm tasting it I'm saying like yes
she doesn't take a shot what do you say
before you drink John Chen done that's a
flag for Cheers
John since I'm younger when I drink I
have to turn my face around I can't face
you guys why so it's like how dare am i
to look at your face here you'll be my
thing great the last round right can I
cook this one right don't trust it
oh wait no hey it's cooking really fast
dated you know when you go out to eat
with friends and it's like what do you
want I don't know you choose this is the
place you go you guys should go ahead
and help yourself right now that's
amazing yeah as any customer ever said I
love you I love you I love that guy so
the final meat is a skirt here we should
also be adding this one oh the perfect
medium-rare edible I got a juicy morsel
here for you
right now I don't know how anything is
gonna beat this you calling it right now
oh what a meat I like that know what was
amazing about that place Jaden this
video is just turning into a crush on
Jaden video Korea fact did you know that
the first Korean astronaut brought
kimchi to space holy and did you know
that a lot of Koreans have a kimchi
refrigerator
oh that is true I don't have one my
uncle has one we know it's funny though
people don't use kimchi refrigerator to
store kimchi they just put the regular
stuff that they will put in the
refrigerator we are currently on our way
to quarters it is not all you can eat
and everything is served in what a
pounds that's why it's called oh you
know your stuff orders is the JIT you
have to wait at least two hours
I like k-town guys it's cute do your
cute thing my name is Jun I'm a manager
of Porter Square BBQ it's very unique
what kind of atmosphere you can provide
is the first one you know send us with
the bar and the Korean barbecue
restaurant together we are here to serve
you we cook everything for you actually
if you can't chill have a great time
with your family friends so we just came
from in all-you-can-eat ways why this
our car we want to do a better quality
to customers every meats are flying you
get it all from four or five different
companies every day and what happens
with your lap over me we serve it all
really yes today we are going to serve
it for nacho rip a spice pork chow
regular pork chop for color and cruel
prove okey then again you're gonna
picture with the cheese fondue together
I mean I'm ready to eat
let's do it let's eat something yeah you
say okay what is that somebody's like
little brother little bro he with that
salad what do you call it an order
brother Tong young you guys are my
tongues there's some tanking for my
thumb saying thank you oh oh the cheese
has arrived bulgogi og of Korean
barbecue Oh
eggs baby what that's beanbag you
reinvent the shoe it's what that soft
I hate chewing didn't you once say ham
you guys the same age actually if you're
born the same year you consider saving
your there chingle chingle chingle
cheers oh this is super good really
tender at the masterpiece soup break or
play a drinking game let's do a crane
game so they're just game called Titanic
you put an empty shot glass in here and
you float it and then you pour a little
bit a little bit taking turns so whoever
sinks up shot glass has to drink their
everything interesting interesting if I
lose this game camera dies driving oh
there we go all right you go first oh
there we go
the strategy is not put the least so
that the next person will actually lose
make it real dangerous let's do
something like what are we eating this
this is my favorite part of work you go
down you don't have some olive oil also
you eat this we're putting the netting
in the cheese oh look at that cheese
it's so good I mean this is straight-up
like cheesy fatty chewy goodness is
there a simple game we take turn
flicking this like that whoever gets it
off don't drink the rest of us drinks oh
yeah I'm gonna start okay
sings dirtier than you think it's gonna
be
ie well I got angry or just injury
strong
[Music]
kinda tastes like bacon better picture
alright our last dish and this is what
the fondue is for the quality of the
meat was incredible the meat was more
fewer cans can cover that pure me with
cheese look at this point of our time
together I'm like ready to just bring it
in guys what's going on here we're a
family now my team do my own thing a
wimp one more place to go so yeah they
can tear it all apart you never know I
don't know how I feel about that cheese
the meat not marinated no cheese was the
best counter-argument cream barbecue as
I've learned today is about eating a lot
of different flavors so to have the
marinated meat with the cheese is a good
break from just the really delicious
meat on its own that's a match made in
heaven that's a match made by Evan
speaking of Evan that about 20 percent
of the Korean population at last names
Kim that's a lot Kim's are the Smiths of
the Korea yeah and Smith's I don't even
know that many Smith's shout out to the
Smiths so on our way to the final place
the luxury Korean barbecue place
you know actually never went to this
place because it was so expensive the
guy himself who eats Korean barbecue
every other week it doesn't even come
here alright I got you guys today
Stephens painting right it's aren't Adam
my name is Aram I'm a manager so I'm
Gabi today I'm gonna introduce what's
the true
Korean barbecue what makes you guys
different from other Korean barbecue
restaurants we are using the fresh meat
which means that we really really care
about the quality for the fresh meat how
fresh is it like the other farm in the
backyard of course some people when they
cut the meat temperature is it up and
down then our meat we always take care
about the environment
you're keeping it at the best
temperature the whole time through the
cutting process through everything yes
which mean that quality is not up and
down and then we keeping their taste
today I'm gonna introduce we can call
the cosa which means Laur me when you
see the meat that's gonna be marbling
just like a flower pop out that fresh
fry me that's really nice high-quality
hot pot soup and also sea bass is one of
them popular in this restaurant one of
the great singer he ordered the sea bass
and the next day I got the phone call he
asked me about the rest of people who's
a singer Stevie Wonder whoa what that's
when you know well this Stevie not so
wonderful is going to be trying some
that Chilean sea bass we made it we're
the final destination that is a movie
about friends who died together yeah
don't say you got to do this why we just
do it there are a lot of things to do
you don't know why you do it but you
just do
yes sir
we just had two Korean barbecue places
and I'm starving again just looking at
this food let's eat it's really see back
one pound Chilean sea bass that's the
first I then we're gonna be eating today
where you cook it inside the kitchen and
not on our grill it's more like no chill
see this look at the way this flakes
apart to Evan to me
well that is really good woah holy
there's no bone here you know that we
tender on the inside
luxurious first meat coat stop flogging
it oh yeah this meat looks incredible
mmm this is like the marbling on that is
ridiculous look at this little bundle of
joy
[Music]
and you want this
if you'd like we're in a Korean drama
right now I don't want to miss it
you need a grinder
[Music]
holy moly incredible and this like
pierces through the flavor and refresh
yes I do like how here you can make the
decision customized mix-and-match put it
together what's next
some cup side oh my favorite what is it
poor one belly it's a Korean bacon
except it's 5,000 times better
five thousand five thousand times look
I'm much better my lettuce wrap
oh my goodness
oh the octopus in here with plan grab
the whole ocean is represented here
[Music]
perfect thing for a cold rainy day right
we've done it the ultimate cream bar
really experience speechless
hey feeling about jadam now move down a
little bit about Danny you'll always be
in my heart feel a lot closer to you
guys I get to pull you guys dreams we
get to talk about lives no that's the
whole Korean barbecue experience I think
I need to meet somebody else at Titanic
let's sing the [ __ ] like you should go
glass oh I like the way you drive am i
worth it winner today was Boop everybody
eats as much as they want as little as
they want and you don't worry about it
because everybody pays the same same
price you had a little bit of a crush on
Jaden that's how I felt about the
server's at Joseph's mature her more
experienced female servers chosun galbi
that's my were that winner
second place quarters it was very hip
was very young that place is designed
for people like us just wants to have
fun orders my wallet three-way Adam
break the tie for us I win I'm the
winner
you didn't win we all wanted a
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]